crazy stupid love drive and now this
this is like the year of Gosling right
now you okay we're gonna be fine
we have to do it the right thing to do
and nothing bad happens when you're
doing the right thing this is your
personal theory because I can shoot
holes in it
well there's exceptions to every rule
Ides of March is directed by George
Clooney stars Ryan Gosling George
Clooney Philip Seymour Hoffman Paul
Giamatti Evan Rachel Wood Marissa Tomei
as well this is like an all-star cast
headed by a great actor who is now
getting really famous as being an
actually really good filmmaker
I really like this film good night and
good luck but that was excellent I had a
lot of fun with leather heads Ides of
March tells the tale of George Clooney a
guy who's in the run to hopefully be a
president one day Ryan Gosling is a guy
who's kind of like a campaign manager
he's in charge of a lot of different
things that are said about him helps him
with his speeches things like that a lot
of things behind the scenes and this
film is a drama largely about how
different it is behind the cameras and
behind what you see on the podium of
things that are actually happening
behind the scenes corruption and all
different types of secrets and things
are kept from people and it's about how
the characters have to change who they
are as people to be able to survive in
this world this political world is this
country you got a couple of minutes I'd
like to sit down with you I can't be
talking to you you got something the
other guys
don't have you considered something you
draw PayPal and you're the big man on
campus I'm just a lowly intern well tell
me I work tomorrow 9:00 a.m. this is an
excellent movie this is a fantastic
movie
it's expertly directed by Clooney
seriously the guy is talented this guy
is serious
talent man he's keys he's a great actor
and he's a very good director this is
definitely my favorite film I've seen of
his Gosling is fantastic in the movie in
fact all the actors are great come on
you got Paul Giamatti Philip Seymour
Hoffman Ryan Gosling you know these
people are proven to be excellent actors
this year Paul Giamatti had win-win
which is one of my favorites of the year
which you guys need to see Philip
Seymour Hoffman Moneyball Ryan Gosling
Crazy Stupid Love and drive I mean these
guys are hot this year I work the more
campaigns than most people I had by the
time they're 40 he's the only one that's
gonna actually make a difference in
people's want either we're going to lead
the world or we are going to bury our
heads in the sand now here's the thing
about this movie that impressed me the
most if there is one thing on this
planet that I am least interested in its
politics
I literally have absolutely nothing to
say about politics and yet this movie
kept me riveted
I was completely interested in this film
from start to finish and that's because
of a brilliant script I really think
this script is excellent it's one of the
best scripts of the year and I'll tell
you why this is a film of inaction it's
a film where people sit and they talk
and they try to live their lives and try
to survive in this world and deal with
all different types of things behind the
scenes that I won't dare give away
because of that you need a script that
seems real you need characters that feel
real people that seem like they are
actual people in in a real world
situation and this movie feels so real I
really got an Aaron Sorkin buy from the
script I want you to work from us
cause my friend there's only one thing I
value in this world and that's loyalty
without it you're nothing you want to
work for the friend what do you want to
work for the president I don't have to
play dirty anymore
I got Morris I'm kind of like the
perfect person to recommend this movie
because I just don't have an opinion in
regards to politics the people who are
going to say bad things about this movie
are the people who are going to look at
the film's political side and judge it
based off of that I'm judging this movie
as filmmaking filmmaking this is
absolutely fantastic it's a wonderful
story great acting excellent script
terrific direction really good music
also by Alexandra desk plot it's how you
say it I personally think that Gosling
is worthy of an Oscar for acting and I
think Clooney is worthy for an Oscar for
directing they're both I mean they're a
great team in this movie I would love to
see them do another movie together you
really want this story getting out
Dignity matter you were off the campaign
but you thought it was important to fix
things
integrity our future
another cool thing about this movie is
it takes place all in Ohio which is
where I'm from
so I was on the lookout you know are
they saying things right are they
getting things right they filmed a lot
of colleges and locations that I myself
have actually been to which is really
cool so it felt very realistic and that
way for me as well because I live right
near many of the places they filmed and
I recognized I was like okay yeah that's
totally that that's that and all the
things they say we're how Ohioans
actually say it to really think you
should see I think it's one of the best
films of the year excellent scripts such
good dialogue interesting dialogue good
things to say really well directed I
can't find a thing that didn't like why
this movie I loved it so I'm gonna get
by it's March and a it's a great film
definitely check it out I'll do or say
anything if I believe in it but I have
to believe in the cars
if you like my review can subscribe my
channel and get stuck my eyes